I was experimenting with like the golden
ratio like seven columns and like twelve
columns all these different grids how
would you go about picking the grid for
a project that fits it's the constant
that make sense yeah I good good
question
I don't think okay there's a lot to be
made about grids and I think in some
cases people ignore them and some people
worship them and I don't think either is
totally right I think it's usually
somewhere in between now I'm going to
show you how to deal with this grid
thing here so this is the fibonacci
sequence and the Fibonacci sequence is
fantastic as a as a grid that's very
dynamic
and I want to show you how to do that I
want to repeat this across and the
easiest way to repeat is to grab this
and then just go like this and hit that
and then hit command-d it just
duplicates it hopefully I've done this
right so that it's correct
like it's not misaligned
there we go so the Fibonacci sequence is
you take two numbers and then you add it
and that equals the second number or the
third number or the sequence so it's one
and then and these are the two numbers
you start out with okay
so you add up those two numbers I know
equal to you add up 1 into 2 equals 3
and then 2 & 3 equals 5 3 & 5 equals 8 &
8 & 5 equals 13 and 13 and 8 equals 21
and that's your Fibonacci sequence okay
now this number there's some very
special things about this number
sequence that was discovered and so what
we can do is we can use that so I'm
gonna take all these things I'm gonna
move it down and I'm gonna move it here
right so one one and then I'm gonna do
two so let me hit this so you can see a
little bit better and three
one two three four five one two three
four five six seven eight okay that's as
far as I can go because I'm gonna run
out of space so if you look at this
ratio of blue blocks here you'll see
that it's actually very dynamic so 1 1 2
3 5 8 right and we can leave the rest
alone and it's gonna make sense in a
little bit
not just yet so if I scale this up
holding that shift oops I need to drop
the anchor point right here hold on
shift and make it fit on this page okay
if I were doing this like it mattered
like I got paid for this I would spend a
little bit more time working on this
than now and then I'm gonna bring on my
guides and hit command hard to bring the
rulers out and now I'm gonna snap it to
that point can you guys see the
guideline right there I can go and
change this color here I like a less
obnoxious like really brilliant blue
guide because it's overpowering
sometimes and I'm gonna do lines so you
can see it very clearly now okay you see
that guide so that's one one right so
I'm gonna do it again snap it to this
and just keep going I'm sure something
faster way of doing this I'm not that
person today okay so if I grab all these
things now I'm gonna rotate this 90
degrees I lost a piece let me group this
okay so I'm gonna rotate this now I
could start this this is kind of like
the the decision that you have to make
as a designer as to where this grid
wants to start and it's just something
to help you not something to enslave you
okay let's say like I like where this
starts here so now I'm gonna pull
gridlines down here
everybody's following me so far and when
I start using this grid you'll start to
see like wow that's that's really how
you use it so I'm gonna flip it using
the mirroring tool which is keyboard
shortcut oh and holding that option as I
click on this it'll flip it upside down
okay now I can also pull this grid so it
could start here so it repeats that
direction or I could do it like
repeating here but I think I'm gonna try
it here all right everybody see the grid
now I'm gonna put this somewhere else
now what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
add bounding boxes or gridlines for the
page itself okay there we are so there's
our
the Fibonacci grid arbitrarily decided
on the horizontal access here and you
can see that now if I were to place
typography in these boxes and use this
to govern how I'm gonna do a layout I'm
gonna show you okay so I'm gonna switch
my color now back to black alright I got
black ink so I were to draw a box so the
rule of using the grid is this is like
the first thing that you put on a page
is arbitrary it's the only thing that's
arbitrary at that point so why isn't
snapping - okay I'm gonna put something
down right here okay that's the first
thing that's it now you have to make
decisions based on that one thing that
you put on the page so if I say like I
want something to relate to that I may
want to create something here and I want
to create something down here okay so
this is how you use the grid system so
that you can create dynamically
proportionate things that kind of feel
related to each other and as soon as I
add or change one element on here it
impacts the layout the feeling of the
layout and if it feels off-balance then
this first thing those arbitrary needs
to move and this is the pushing pool of
typography and design you put that in
that one dot now you kind of have to
move things around to make it work
within that so this also teach you
things like this I'm going to show you
something let me move this out of the
way let me just delete that you could
take this sucker and you could put it
over here so I'm gonna
right now you can see like this will be
related to this this is related to that
this is not a terribly interesting
layout and this is to remind you just
because you use a grid does it mean it's
good it's just a starting point for us
to work if you want to learn more about
typography you can check out the
typography critiques that we're doing
right here on the future academy channel
and if you really want to dive deep we
have a typography course that you can
find on our website the future comm
enrolling in the course also gives you
the opportunity to submit your work for
any live critiques conducted by Cristo